[Music]
you are not you perceive mint or
pata piquouse libertine
reports
[Music]
so we left in fact reims
which is an hour and a half from paris we are
part of the convoy of freedom
today we are  over there against the
vaccination pass but not only also for all
the taxes that the government
imposes on us in fact here is
[Music]
all
he tries to bring everyone back to the West Indies
vague me I am vaccinated I have the three
doses I understand  that people
are wondering about the
long-term effects but I'm not anti
vaccines I'm a scientist
so we have to stop the costs today
if it conveys and people here
what are these poverty wages we don't
wants more that we can live with dignity
from work so we must increase
wages
[Music]
[Applause]
rights our freedoms are violated we
just have the right to work drac they
were taxes is the fruit of diesel
increases wheat increases the  juice  re
increases the insurance increases the
wines everything increases in addition
to sanitary measures totally stupid
[Music]